the National Archives is in possession
of thousands of email from Joe's time as
VP where he apparently as Sean has
reported used a pseudonym
lots of different names with Burner
email accounts want a government account
others Gmail accounts and use them to
communicate frequently with Hunter see
see him on things but it was about
official government business oftentimes
but that's not all according to American
first legal Hunter's firm Rosemont
Seneca get this one this is new
exchanged over a thousand emails so
Hunter's firm exchanged over a thousand
emails with Joe Biden's vice
presidential office Through official
email traffic
so what's going on here simple question
we'll see if there's a simple answer
let's bring in Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett and former Florida attorney
general Pam Bondi uh Greg the you know
the emails are the names are Robert L
Peters and Robin Ware and jrb Ware
reminds me of Carlos Danger and Pierre
delecto except this is a lot more
significant because it's the President
and Vice President of the United States
with foreign entities he told us he knew
nothing about it and day after day after
day we see how intertwined it is Greg
yeah I mean think about it
5400 Alias emails under fake accounts I
mean that's a staggering number just do
the math that's almost two of these
clandestine emails a day during his vice
presidency uh so you know why was Joe
Biden doing it well Occam's razor tells
us the obvious answer usually the
correct one in this case it's
concealment if somebody has nothing to
hide they don't hide their
Communications but people who engage in
improper if not illegal activities cloak
them in a shroud of Darkness they try to
obscure their illicit behavior and
that's what Joe Biden was doing here
Hunter was being copied on his dad's
secretive emails that dealt directly
with Ukraine where the song was
pocketing a million dollars per year and
some of the shared Communications were
with then president poroshenko whom Joe
pressured to fire the prosecutor who is
investigating Hunter Biden and his
company barisma so you know these Alias
emails Pete are only solidifying Joe's
direct involvement in his son's schemes
it strikes me to Pam that like a lot of
this information if it involves high
level interactions with government
officials would have some level of
classification at which point Hunter
didn't have one but worked for different
firms uh how I mean you can connect the
dots now with the crayon
um when when does it really Cascade into
something meaningful in your mind I mean
it's already meaningful with the
evidence we have but it is something
that really moves
yeah it is it is it is Pete and I think
it's so important to know that I believe
that an impeachment inquiry is imminent
regarding Joe Biden and here's why James
Comer and the house oversight committee
they need subpoena power and now more
than ever they need subpoena power and
these emails are critical to The house's
investigation and they're not giving
them up they're they're making all these
ridiculous claims some of them they're
claiming executive privilege what about
that when they threw executive privilege
out the window to go after president
Trump yet they're claiming it on some of
these emails now so the house oversight
committee has to have subpoena power and
to connect it with crayons let's keep
going 15 trips Hunter Biden took to
foreign companies on Air Force two bank
transfers to 20 shell companies to nine
Biden family members this has got to be
investigated and the house oversight
committee has to have the authority to
do so and the only way way they can get
that Authority is by an impeachment
inquiry so that I believe is soon to
come
Greg makes sense I mean if you've got
these all these bank account scores of
llc's going to different could a
impeachment inquiry truly have the
subpoena power necessary to get to the
bank records that's where the money
actually went from home would they is
that why it's so powerful
yeah I I think so
um I would actually recommend a select
committee uh which is sort of the Apex
of subpoena Authority Under the Nixon
standard during Watergate cases that you
know Nixon tried to Stonewall and
eventually the courts including the
Supreme Court said no you can't not with
a select committee involving you know
illegal activities and a pending
impeachment so I do think that's where
it's hidden heading there are some
moderates who are a bit reluctant I
think this effort at a snap impeachment
without any committee hearings is a
mistake and that's what Nancy Pelosi did
in the second Trump impeachment
um you know two wrongs don't make a
right I think they need to methodically
gather the evidence show it to the
American people before they actually
move toward an impeachment but I agree I
think we're getting closer and closer to
it
Pam what do you think of that and and do
you think we could get to the point
because some had there's some hesitation
amongst moderate House Republicans oh
I'm in a district that went don't you
think it could create a moment where
even Senate Democrats and moderate
Republicans in the Senate might say like
this is just sheer illegality
sure I don't know how someone like Joe
manchin doesn't agree to this as well
absolutely you have to look at this and
again this is there is so much evidence
Pete that is out there and remember Joe
Biden said I had no contact with my son
regarding foreign business dealings and
James Comer has said he has seen one of
those emails that was forwarded to
Hunter directly referencing Ukraine
exactly it's outrageous it's right there
it is uh Greg and Pam keep us updated
thank you very much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else